all right guys happy Wednesday we got a
beautiful day out there it is a little
cool to be outside without a jacket or
something warm big woolly sweater
whatever it is that you take out to be
warm you've got to have it today we've
got North winds temperatures in the 40s
couple of neighborhoods in the 30s
Mountains Edge Seven Hills Red Rocks it
freezing but those North winds when
they're blowing and they've still been
up to 25 miles an hour at times that
feels extra chilly it'll cut right
through you we've had stronger winds
still down around Bullhead City and
Laughlin this morning 50 degrees doesn't
feel like 50. it feels like low 40s or
even colder at times with those stronger
winds near freezing in Mesquite mid 30's
in prompt 34 in Indian Springs 21 in
Caliente and single digits up there in
Ely Breezy to Gusty winds will continue
through today and below normal
temperatures we just can't get the
afternoons back where they should be so
warnings will stay extra chilly as well
it continues through the weekend even a
little cooler for Saturday and Sunday
but we will stay sunny and we're staying
very dry with those North winds keep
yourself really hydrated good lotion on
your skin ChapStick and all that really
the West is pretty quiet except for the
wind in the southwest most of the rest
of the West is uneventful boy this is
where it's going with winter weather
across the Great Lakes and upper New
England lots of snow there with the cold
air Santa Ana winds for Southern
California causing elevated fire weather
danger and for Southern Nevada it's wind
advisories with those extra high winds
and wind advisories in place out to the
river down to Laughlin until six o'clock
Southeast California along I-15 as well
and fire weather warnings from Santa
Barbara down to San Diego with those
elevated fire weather concerns Santa Ana
winds easily 50 plus miles an hour today
60 degrees for our high will keep the
temperatures around the same but the
winds will back off for Thursday Friday
and then again a little cooler for the
weekend maybe a few clouds around on
Saturday next week looks like it warms
up a little bit as we head towards
turkey day Wednesday in the mid 60s so
that's looking a little bit better